turning back to the economy and those
worse than expected inflation numbers we
are joined now by cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger good morning
how you doing doing well all right so
gas prices are down over the month but
higher than a year ago other consumer
prices are still up um what's going on
here so this report was really important
because that headline number did go down
it didn't go by down go down by as much
as expected but i think the other areas
of the report were really somewhat
worrisome so let's look at food costs
which were up by more than 11 from a
year ago that's the fastest annual
acceleration since 1979.
so that's a big number and then we look
at shelter the number isn't that big
it's up 6.2 from a year ago but think
about how much money of your household
goes towards rent or paying for your
house so that core inflation rate all
the other stuff besides food and energy
rising pretty substantially that's the
worrying aspect of the report great the
news that gas prices are down but
everything else is still expensive but
inflation has been here for months so
why the market plunge so i think it's
all about these expectations because
there was some hope that inflation would
come down by more at the headline and
then the core prices would sort of
stagnate and now we have a bunch of
investors who say oh my god now we
really are going to see the fed act next
week there's going to be a third three
quarters of a percentage point increase
maybe the fed is going to take us into a
recession and there's great fear that
the fed's going to have to raise rates
by even more than expected and that just
raising those interest rates is going to
slow things down too much okay jill we
got uh holiday shopping around the
corner will these prices come down
well here's the issue i think there's
another aspect to the selloff in stocks
i think that there is a worry that
consumers if you're paying so much for
food for gas for energy for everything
else that you are not going to have as
much money to spend on the holiday
season and i'm unfortunately here to
report that i don't think prices are
going to come down substantially in the
next few months and that means that you
may have to spend a little bit less this
holiday season during the commercial
break i'm going to ask you about the r
word recession because it seems like it
keeps we'll do that next week no doubt
jill schlesinger thank you